hey what's up guys my name is Jonah
welcome back to my game engine series so
last time we took a look at the input
manager and we've kind of made an input
polling system definitely take a look at
that video if you haven't already and
today we're going to kind of continue on
with that and do something that I wanted
to do for a while and that is to
actually create our own kind of hazeled
cake heads and mouse button codes right
so this might be a problem that a lot of
uterine realize we actually have but
essentially what we're relying on right
now is the gfw api for the definitions
of key codes now the reason that that's
a problem is because first of all it
ties us very heavily to gel W second of
all it means the gel W has to be known
by the actual client not just the engine
so what I mean by that is let's just say
you're inside your game or your
application that uses hazel right so you
don't you know this isn't actually the
hazel library this is your actual
application your client and then you
want to check to see if the spacebar is
pressed right well to do that at the
moment what you have to do is basically
write code that's like input is key
pressed J love W key space or something
right something like that we don't want
to do that because that means that you
actually have to include jelf W into
your application we don't want that wait
the only thing you should be including
in in your application really is hazel
now you know there are other things that
you will use for example you know SPT
log has to be included in some sense
because we just have macros which expand
to kind of SPT log things then the other
thing you actually need to have included
would be like what's the other thing
I'm GUI right so I'm doing something
that you would write kind of client side
as well but with things like W you know
we don't we don't want to have any kind
of relation to that the reason that's a
problem as well is that you know I am
GUI back that's gonna be used on all
platforms SPG Louis every user on all
platforms jello W though might not
always we might not always use gel up W
so at the moment we're using it for
Windows Mac and Linux
essentially right that's kind of the
plan but in the future you know in my
you might want to use the win32 API and
then like on Windows and then Mac Linux
maybe we'll just stick with your table
you for Mac and Linux so immediately
that creates a problem because
everything is tied to gel W we don't
even need gfwl windows that's an issue
now the other big thing though is that
gel W key codes are actually different
than certain other kickers for example
the win32 api defines the key codes as
actual different constants right
different integers different values than
gel if W does so that's a problem
because you know if we rely on gel of W
and we switch the win32 API we can't
keep using those same constants we need
some kind of if there's some kind of
conversion like strategy or like some
kind of like lookup table to kind of
translate between the two or maybe we
need to change the original key codes on
Windows it's like a whole kind of mess
that gets created so that's kind of what
we're gonna address in this episode we
don't actually have to do much work
today because we are kind of tied to gel
W all I want to do is just get rid of
that GL help you dependency for our key
codes and essentially set up a very
simple system and also show you guys
around the code a little bit as to what
you can what you will actually have to
do and why this is a problem and all
that so let's just jump into the code I
think I'm gonna just stop talking for
now let's jump into the code and we'll
take a look at like the situation and
what we can actually do about it okay so
to reiterate the problem right now
rather the previous episode when we made
this input class and we did all of that
we tested it out in application which
was great right so we had application
run we didn't forget Mouse position
we've got all of our stuff that's great
Mouse position is an easy one now if we
actually do something like inputs is key
pressed Wiens Brewin we need to provide
a key code now we are inside application
it doesn't repeat which is inside hazel
I don't think we actually include shelf
W here but at them at the minute well
what we would actually have to do is
something like Jill of w key tab right
that's a problem because we have to
include shelf W to do that now this
problem is even worse if you take this
and you decide actually I want to do
this in
actual sandbox app this is not in the
hazel project this is inside the sandbox
project right it's in a completely
different place we definitely don't want
to include GLW here this is our client
right so and yet if I want to do
something like this or maybe in the on
update I just want to see if this is
press right so let's just do some code
like that if that's pressed then you
know we'll do something like HSN in for
tab key it's pressed right
that's our goal kind of for today we
want to be able to do something like
this but without including shelf w how
do we do that when we just make sure the
way hazel and I think we'll probably
have to update hazel dot H to include
I'll always like forget to do this I'll
probably do this as we go along I don't
want to sit there and write this whole
thing out but you know we'll kind of
have this in roughly alphabetical order
we'll have input here and then you can
see now what this is the problem so what
we want to do instead is do something
like H set key tab right so we're kind
of depending on hazel key codes now
instead of actually the job W once which
is fantastic because again that means
that we're eliminating that dependency
to digital of W but also making sure
that no matter what library we end up
using in the backend will always have
one kind of set of key codes that can be
accessible and that's it so to kind of
further illustrate this problem a little
bit if we actually go to jail w3 dot H
which is the header file and we look at
um job W key tab you know here it is we
have a bunch of constants here bunch of
defines this is defined to be 258 that's
great right 258 whatever here's the
issue if we look at the virtual key
codes defined by Microsoft rises in the
win32 API look at this tab over here is
defined to be nine nine okay it's an
accidental but it's the same in decimal
nine 258 and nine clearly they're
different numbers right so we can't
actually they're not compatible with
each other so what we need to
essentially do is choose one convention
we either do like this we could
obviously invent our own key codes as
well but that's not really about
there's no benefit to doing that we
either pick like Microsoft's ones we
pick job W is ones and we kind of just
stick with that and then if we're on a
different platform we could do some kind
of conversion where necessary either a
compile time if we really wanted to or
even at run time so I'll show you how
that works so the first thing we're
gonna do is actually steal this okay I
don't really care about the unknown key
but all of these printable keys what we
kind of begin here I'm just gonna copy
and paste this entire block okay
and then I'm going to make a file just
in here called key codes dot H all right
and I'm just gonna paste all of this in
here now
Jill of W I'm going to hit ctrl H and I
don't know if you'll get you guys will
be able to see this
maybe if I drag it over here you'll
definitely see it I'm just gonna find
and replace shelf W like that on the
store with H set underscore and alt a
will replace it everywhere in this
current document and there we go
so now we've effectively stolen shelf
double use key codes here now again we
might want to redefine certain things so
for example you know they they've like
getting a decimal divide like maybe
you're not happy with like some key
codes like this one's called super this
actually refers to the Windows key or if
you're on Mac the command key I don't
know some people don't like the name
super they think it's weird they might
like rename it to Windows key obviously
I'm just gonna keep it as super because
we do support more than just Windows and
so we don't want to tie anything to like
be windows care whatever we have the key
pad stuff anyway
this looks pretty good to me I'm
obviously gonna add a comment from Jeff
w3h okay just so that we know if we want
to update this or if we want to refer to
this or somehow this has changed but
that's the basic gist of it right I'm
also going to add a new item
I had a file here called mouse button
codes and then this will be and then
this will be kind of the same will go to
job w3 Jeff W mouse button and then
we'll just grab all of these
and there's a bunch of mods as well
which we could worry about they're just
certain bits that are set there for
modifier flies by the actual gfw
functions we're not gonna bother for now
if we do need them in the future we will
use them and then over here I can just
quickly replace this to be H said and
then same with here okay and again I'll
have my little comment from WH and there
we go okay cool
so we have our mouse button codes and we
have our key codes these header files
are really light as well obviously that
just defines which is really nice no
functions here no symbols really just
defines so that is quite good and we
have pretty much everything we need now
here's the thing and what I'll do office
Li is I'll go to that Haysville header
file of mine and I'll include you know
Haysville mouse button codes hazel key
codes okay might just put input into its
own little section here like that okay
cool so there we go
we've got all of that stuff now if we go
to sandbox app obviously this works and
guess what if we actually test this it
will work right so if I go into head
into application just gonna get rid of
this stuff that we talked about last
time I also don't really particularly
want to log every event right now so
I'll just comment that out hopefully I
think we'll only have this left so let's
just see what this looks like okay so
here's our application this is our log
so we're still doing example layout
update but if I hit the tab key you can
see it says tap case pressed I might
just um get rid of that and maybe just
make this trace so that it's not green
okay so we have this now and if I hit
the tab key you can see it says tap keys
pressed okay I'm holding it down so
there we go that now works and
everything's fine we've just kind of
stolen GLW gets its key codes and
everything's fine now let's talk about
conversions and where that might be
necessary where it won't be necessary
and what I even mean by that so again
the problem here that we're trying to
solve is potentially if we switch from
gel W to win32 these will be different
right what I mean by that is at the
moment if you take a look at what's
happening we do is key pressed right we
go to the windows
imitation of that and then we look up
shelf wk get K but what if we're doing
the win32 API version of this function
right we need to provide a win32 API key
code right so here are your options and
what you could essentially do the first
thing you could do is probably the most
efficient in terms of runtime cost and
that is to basically say that well hang
on a minute
if we are on a certain platform and when
we compile hazel and it's application on
a certain platform for a certain target
we know what the actual like windowing
library or whatever will be right we
know if we're using jelf w we know if
we're using win32 api we know what we're
doing so what we could do is just based
on the platform that we're compiling for
change these codes to be the correct
ones for that given platform so in other
words if we did go with the kind of
scenario that I came up with where where
we have hazel on Mac and Linux using gel
FW and hazel on Windows using win32 API
then when we compile you know we could
have like a you know if def h dead
platform windows we have windows key
codes otherwise if it's a dead platform
mac OS I just said platform Linux we
have gel W key codes what that means is
that any runtime checks we do this
constant is actually different based on
the platform we've compiled for right
so again if it's Windows this would be
defined to be 9 if it's because 9 is the
one that we have here right
whereas makkal init Mac or Linux this
would be 258 now that's great you could
do it that way there's nothing wrong
with doing it that way I think that's
one of your options and that's kind of
the what if I lost my eye here it is
lost my windows input that's one of the
options it's not bad the only problem
with that that I can really say is that
if you decide to somehow sterilize that
data or store it it wouldn't really be
compatible with you know with the other
kind of key code I guess values so for
example let's just say that I have a
save file for my game i bring mapped you
know
to play a remap certain key codes to be
other key codes right because usually
you kind of in games you're able to
change your controls to be whatever they
whatever you want them to be and then
I've just sterilized you know the tab
key as like the number nine that's not
gonna be compatible with 258 right which
is what it is right now through JW they
can those kickers are going to be
different so again hypothetically
speaking I copy and paste my key code
like save file or whatever let's just
say like my input like preferences I
copy and paste that file from my Windows
computer to my Mac computer and run
hazal on that that's not gonna work
right it's not going to know what the
tab key is because you've sterilized it
you've see realized it as a number and
that's what it expects it to be now you
could solve this by just utilizing a
string which says tab or something like
that and then add what I want to
deserialize is it it can look up the
actual value and then you'd be so kind
of set there but again that's something
that you just have to do because if you
kind of at runtime
if you've hard-coded your keys to be a
certain code that is like either the gel
w1 or the windows one you have to kind
of stick with that the whole way through
that's kind of the downside of that the
other thing you could do is have a
function and this is quite common as
well to have a function that actually
converts between the key codes as
necessary right just a lookup table
essentially so for example edge set key
for is that value sure but when you
interact with gfw for example in windows
window when we actually do you know the
key callback right and we have to do a
key pressed event with this key you do a
conversion so you do something like
chill of w key to H set B right little
function which might just be a lookup
table into a map or something like that
which just converts this job W key code
into the correct hazel key code and
that's the one that you pass into that
event right and then that's obviously
for events and then for polling which is
this thing when you get the key code
here before you pass it into here you
just do H set key code to gel up W key
code right and then you do that
conversion here and that's it and that
does mean that every time you do a key
press or anything like that you do have
to do a lookup into a map in my
experience that's fine like I don't
I've never ever in the history of my
life seen like a bottleneck of a game
engine be art because I'm doing little
cups for key codes right a lot of people
I think like to do a lot of
optimizations that's completely
unnecessary in certain areas where they
think that they can save like a few CPU
cycles whereas in other areas where it's
much more important and much more kind
of damaging to not do optimization they
seem to overlook that because it's just
too complicated or people don't think
about it in that sense so I think that's
a that's an optimization that like I
think the performance difference between
just compiling with the correct key
codes in the first place versus a V
having a lookup table that you need to
look up every time you press a key I
that's negligible right there's no
difference there as far as I'm concerned
so I wouldn't worry about that at all
based on those two methods I think what
I probably would do is still always have
hazel key codes as a constant that is
always the case at runtime and then when
you interact with different libraries
which require different key codes that's
when you can actually do what you need
to do now and and when and by that I
just mean convert it into the into the
right actual key code now one thing I
will say though is that we know that
these are java key codes right so the
function that you know if we're in
windows window and we're in gfw set
cakehole back and we need to do this we
actually know that node conversion is
necessary because we're using the right
ones so you would only need to do this
conversion for when you interact with
libraries other than JAL fw and again if
we had just made up random key codes or
something like that for for all these
values then we would need to do a
conversion every time now these aren't
completely random like these like a
being 65 that lines up with ASCII codes
right so that's quite useful because you
can basically grab this H set key F and
just converted into a char and then
suddenly you can actually print that
character to the console by just
printing H that key F right so what I
mean by that is you know okay well we
have a this one event thing right so
let's just get a you know instead of
tracing this or whatever I'll say
if the events type is a key event and
key pressed event I wish that it would
actually show me what I wanted
he pressed event then we can get the key
events of the key pressed event and
we'll just cost this into the right type
all right and then we'll just do a get
key code what I can actually do is log
that
so we'll say H said trace and I'll put
this in here except what I'll do is I'll
actually passed it to a charm okay so if
I try and log something like this you'll
see that for values that I like stupid
like ctrl or shift or whatever it might
be stupid but if we actually press you
know a you know SD you know if I type in
the word public public static I was
gonna write but you can see if I type
that word in like you can actually see
what the letters are by just casting
this to a char because the key code that
we're using actually lines up with ASCII
codes so they're not completely random
and that's why making your own random
ones will be weird but obviously with
things like tab and I think that they
I'm not sure why they chose them to be
what they are like for example why tab
is 258 I don't know the back story
behind that but you know certain ones
like letters you do want to actually
line up with ASCII characters just
because you have kind of those benefits
there anyway that's kind of the gist of
it I mean there's nothing really here to
be too concerned about I'll leave this
card in here and I'll commit it into the
repository for this video but yeah you
can see that now we have the ability to
do polling by that and we also have the
ability to actually do events kind of
stuff events
I guess key events and then we can we
have the correct key codes then we can
actually just print to the console and
now we have like this is the big thing
obviously with this as well you could do
comparisons now so if the yet key code
is equal to tab then you could also
- tap Keys press for example and then
that would be instead of kind of pulling
it and checking every time you can just
handle it when it actually gets pressed
but the point is we can now do this
comparison so I'll do event here hole
okay and we can actually see the
difference here as well but you can now
kind of do both of these things that
weren't possible before without
including JFW
so there we go we have obviously the
ASCII character for tap is not there but
we have the poll and we have the event
okay so that's pretty cool but yeah we
have the ability now to do these kind of
comparisons with certain key codes and
as well as like asked what key is
pressed without actually including GLW
at all so I think that's pretty cool and
that's again gonna be really important
for when we actually need to use these
features all right so I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did hit that
like button
you're not support the stairs by going
over to pay for an accomplice at the
chair no huge thank you as always to all
the lovely patrons there for supporting
you'll get videos a week early as well
as access to the hazel development
branch source code which is actually
getting quite exciting now because I've
just started on the render and like the
render command cues and like that's
gonna be all kind of it's multi-threaded
and everything so things are heating up
there I can't wait to actually start
working on this stuff in the videos but
we do still have quite a long way to go
until we get up to like the exciting
stuff that is on that developing branch
so if you want to sneak peek definitely
check that out now in terms of what
we're doing next we have a lot of
options a lot of juicy options because
we're at the point now where we have
kind of events input application layer
stack that kind of stuff and done there
is the kind of the base features that
you really need to build it build up as
well as logging and I'm go as well I
really like to have there are some I'm
doing things that I want to do
eventually the hazel development branch
at the moment has a version of iron GUI
which supports both docking so you can
actually dock things kind of like you
can in Visual Studio as well as drag
windows outside of your window so you
can place windows outside of the window
it will just kind of create a new window
behind the scenes it's really cool
I want to integrate that into hazel
eventually I might not do that next
steps there because it feels like what
kind of going
run in circles and iterating so much or
more we've got instead of introducing
new features I know you guys are excited
to see some of those new features so why
don't you leave a comment below as to
what you actually want to see Max and
Hazel at the moment I think what I'm
going to do like we have a few options
so we could just like go continue going
the kind of back end like let's just
build stuff up that we need in the
background without actually seeing stuff
on the screen kind of written that route
and actually do ization because that
needs to be done at some point but and
much more exciting topic which we might
want to do is rendering write and
graphics and that kind of stuff but
there's also like this much stuff
working - we can go scripting languages
and kind of take a look at those I don't
actually actually even know what I want
to use might be a little mobile Python
might be something like that I'm not
sure there's so much stuff that we can
actually do again start designing tools
like a 3d model format like a level
editor and I'm GUI there's so much stuff
that we can do so just leave a comment
below as to what you want to see and
what you think sounds exciting a lot of
the reasons why I want to make a
renderer it's probably because it will
look nice and then his little it look
nice and then the thumbnails will look
nice and then anyway it would kind of
just be good because you have kind of
something to show because unfortunately
when people look at a game engine they
see kind of superficially like what's it
they're like okay this is what it looks
like
therefore I know how good it is based on
what it's look what it looks like
obviously that's rubbish but that's kind
of how people work so I kind of maybe
want to go that that that kind of route
but if you guys have any suggestions I
just want to kind of basically do what
you guys want to I want to give you guys
what you want to see it's leave a
comment below and I'll see you next time
goodbye
[Music]